yo blue lighthead podcast special guest
in here two guys yes sir to my favorite
artists out of la easy check ruchi is
here yeah sure welcome welcome
first of all
whose idea was it to do a joint album
uh
it was a natural [ __ ] yeah we do you
guys been working so much together we be
thugging together every day so like all
the music that we had we were just like
we got to put it together and get the
fans what they won't type [ __ ] it was
like nobody specifically he was just
like y'all had did you guys just have a
bunch of records together and you were
like man we got all these records again
we might as well just put it together it
was momentum and everybody [ __ ] together
like our camps and [ __ ] and managers so
it was just like
it's a no-brainer yeah for sure yeah
it's a no-brainer last summer really
though we really was just like that's
what we're going to do
okay so i told y'all before the camera
started y'all's album covers
straight out in like 1998. you know what
i'm saying
i love it
i don't think if you guys are on a major
label they were green light using
[ __ ] as tables in 2021 but i love
that energy um who's like you feel like
you feel like who do you feel like a
cancer is who you feel like in kansas i
don't think i don't think anybody will
cancel you guys but i'm saying like if
imagine if like kanye did that they
would try to cancel his ass do you see
this man on your wall what he was doing
he had a whole album called [ __ ]
didn't he
not [ __ ] made him change it that album
came out it was called the n
that's even better and he got whips on
his back
yeah no so yeah the album was supposed
to be called that yeah but that jam made
him change it yeah
the beauty of it though like you know
what i'm saying to be controversial
that's art you know what i'm saying
you're not supposed to like [ __ ] all the
time no i thought it was fire no no not
you just but that's hot you know when we
did the cover that that was like the the
point like all right we know it's gonna
ruffle some feathers but we know some
[ __ ] are gonna love it too i
know what i'm saying they really love
music too and no like to understand the
creators of this i was like this would
be a fire sugar free cover in like
four
you guys had a [ __ ] as a lamb right
yeah this is a lamp table a woman has a
lamp and a woman at the table this is
amazing
can we shout out their only fans
accounts or something just so we can try
to get them some love or like do it like
shout out to them for being real patient
with us
they ain't even know freaks there was
like some little squares like you know
yeah yeah i think they got no only fans
that was probably like some tree hugging
it has [ __ ]
where do you find the girl to sign up to
do that is it like an agency or i think
shout out to like you know the team for
doing that yeah
they got that down but they understood
the assignment yeah i was just curious
like if you know you're on like a
listing like a model thing and it's like
yo uh we need you to be a ta a naked
table they know that before they did it
i mean not before they did it before
they got there
yeah oh yeah that was with it
nice and we painted them all gold so
did you guys actually do the painting
yourselves no we just showed up and took
the pictures
yeah see if i was y'all i'd be like i'm
paying these [ __ ] myself
i'm paying them i'm a painter
[ __ ]
no but it's crazy because like i feel
like the album is man
i feel like it's a perfect album to kind
of bridge into your guys solo [ __ ] which
i'm sure is coming right hell yeah
what up what do you guys um
i mean how many records you guys each
sitting on right now as far as you know
for your personal projects
we don't even know too many yeah a lot
of [ __ ] but you know you still want to
be in a time like i don't even like
doing that [ __ ] i you can have a lot of
records but i still want some get that
fresh [ __ ] i want to do some shout out
just didn't give it to the people i was
gonna say like is that like you just
said everything that happens with a lot
of artists where you have a bunch of
records that are are old to you but it's
new to the people but it's new to the
people and sometimes you might psych
yourself out and not put out some [ __ ]
that's crazy i'll say you put it out not
because you always say you put it out
right
and say it's it's sticking there's some
[ __ ]
and they say you don't even rap like
that no more like you get what i'm
saying it's like damn it comes a little
complicated like right this ain't even
where i'm at creatively like yeah i've
moved from this space already like you
know what i'm saying like that was a
different me in that different time
period that six-month span type [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying well it all worked
out it's still all blended because it's
still all the same person you know what
i'm saying i was gonna say like do you
uh
do you have like your team kind of like
hit you and be like yo i know this song
is old but this is one of them ones yeah
uh our manager picasso will be doing
that [ __ ] most of the time for sure
that's his [ __ ]
he'll do that
i think we just create every day though
we make music every day so
we kind of be like over that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] be hard on that show so it's like
you gotta be some [ __ ] every time we
don't go hey i'm gonna say we go against
it but we do be like well we gotta let
me see what you like so much about this
[ __ ] like you know what i'm saying but
yeah we'd be on the new [ __ ]
ruchi uh your documentary was it last
year that it finally dropped or was it
the year was it 2019 or 2019 2019
documentary was crazy obviously we got
to kind of get to know your pops a bit
in his situation how's he doing for
people who don't know your dad got
deported yeah my dad got deported but
he's living comfortably you know what
i'm saying and where he's at in mexico
he's beautiful right now he ain't
got nothing to worry about you but i'm
saying he got a good job he knows when
to get paid so how often do you like go
go to tj and i ain't been in a minute
because i had no idea i've been oh a
little player i got to get my id because
i ain't trying to go over there and not
be able to you don't have a passport no
bro come on man nah you're a [ __ ]
national recording artist
you gotta get that [ __ ] together hey if
you're trying to book me out of this
country i'm gonna get my passport
that's what it's gonna take
and then they're gonna be like we wanna
book you in a month and it's going to
take you three months to get your
passport
75 bro i'll give you the 75. just go get
it done you go to burbank city hall
you got your passport yeah okay okay at
least one of you two are adults
yeah
you're missing out on the cancun vibes
i'm just
super [ __ ] irresponsible i respect
the uh i respect the honesty super duper
responsible i just got the idea i lost
some already
yeah where did you lose your id i don't
know yeah i know people like you
i i hate when people ask me for that's
the problem stop asking me for it and i
won't lose it you had to pull it out for
where it was
type [ __ ]
are you guys uh planning on doing any
live shows together around the album oh
yeah the finder theater on the 14th
we're doing a ruchi versus chike don't
go crazy you guys gonna do a verses it's
real versus i like that yeah so it'll be
one you guys are going to do a record
one and one and one and one yep and then
we're gonna go and then come together
and do the album together
bring out a gang of special guests oh
it's gonna be a movie not for sure gonna
be a movie oh yeah help me understand
something uh-huh what the hell happened
with draco the ruler because don't you
guys have mutual people involved in each
of your situations so where where did
things go left you know like that we hot
yeah
when the [ __ ] was in jail though
he went i don't know i think it was that
was that tape he dropped in jail
some [ __ ] uh he wanted [ __ ] on there
though
i told him no
because i [ __ ] with inglewood and
that was it he was just mad at that got
out of jail papa fish grease daughter
[ __ ] gonna tuck tail
now we're here
um
i just like i'ma let you take a bong hit
on camera just real quick before we this
is epic it's the first bong hit on the
bootleg hit podcast by the way i just
like the fact that my man travels with a
giant bong not a small bong just a
normal you know
that's a real boy right there
so
do you think the original the the
original issue was with
uchike
and then it kind of just kind of
obviously you guys are doing an album
together and
i mean [ __ ] my city i'm from inglewood
we don't get along bro as a whole you
know what i'm saying so
that's how i move already you feel me
um he
came at him on some [ __ ] basically like
oh you just doing that because you [ __ ]
with them nice homie being loyal bro
right for me but now we just not [ __ ]
with nothing over there
we doing our own thing and
it's like we're not paying attention to
none of them [ __ ] but they
keep hating and keep saying something
about us so it's like we got to give
them a little attention
but other than that no how did you think
what were your thoughts when you heard
the ingo weird joint
i didn't give a [ __ ] but like like like
like like let's say take yourself out of
it and where you're from like did you
like what'd you think of it like as a
song actually was not tight
yeah
it could have been better i [ __ ] the
beat was hard as [ __ ]
better i ain't gonna
you know it doesn't sound threatening
like
man i'm assuming though it's like you
made the song about like type but you
call the englewood type from south
central right you put on sensors like it
was no like
direct like nothing
i'm assuming uh i'm crazy the homie came
crazy
yeah not i mean i think in the track i
don't think people give you enough
credit as a mc
yeah do you think you you're like a bit
slept on when it comes to just like your
talents is like an actual like
dude with the bars yeah but that just me
i got to put more work in it's something
i'm not doing you know i mean like it's
not just even just about that even
though i love that part of it but it's
something else i'm not doing so that's
what i'm figuring out you know what i'm
saying i don't like to complain you're
just gonna keep it rocking you know what
i'm saying but definitely [ __ ]
gonna know though for sure it's slowly
working itself out through the little
altercations and bumping heads and [ __ ]
like that even the album and [ __ ] like
you know what i'm saying
the talent will be displayed i was going
to say with you track like obviously you
guys you and draco have some people that
are mutual of both of your situations
like exactly
like a lot you know what i'm saying so
is that something that's like an easy uh
an easy conversation to have to make
sure it doesn't escalate
uh
yeah but it's like
you know like yeah and
name them [ __ ] not on [ __ ] like
nothing's gonna happen like what i'm
saying is just
um a heated exchange of words like
that's that
all our peoples and mutuals know that
[ __ ] too
so i mean i like it it's on you guys put
it on record right
i mean that's how
we grew up and that's how [ __ ] was back
then yeah you have an issue you guys go
ahead go at each other on the record or
let the fans decide and keep it pushing
hopefully exactly
[Music]
so we used to just type of [ __ ] we've
been going through this [ __ ] before
music
that's some real [ __ ] man
um you guys the show at the founders
what when is it 14th november 14th all
right tickets are on sale right now it's
gonna sell out yeah yeah yeah it's gonna
be a quick sell out we got a
some openers too we got haiti baby lady
baby king most wanted big sad baby stone
gorillas i think haiti baby might be the
most in shape rapper
the flyer he said thing like a superhero
on the [ __ ] is in shape bruh nah
he for sophia on this [ __ ] he owes me a
plaque by the way man me and head need a
plaque haiti baby if you're watching
this we kind of you know we kind of we
had your [ __ ] going crazy on that
freestyle
you went crazy for yourself um
what's the timeline for each of you guys
the solo [ __ ] after after fonda going
into the new year do you guys have any
idea
don't stop we ain't gonna stop like
it's just like what we do so we ain't
gonna try to give it no time frame we
literally gonna just
play this right here what we gonna do
we're gonna make this go to the top
before i'm saying at the same time still
me and ty
talk about the uh
the boozy video shoot looked epic
[ __ ] at a car wash are always fun
you know
um
was that a feature you had to like bag
boozy out for
not for sure but it wasn't like no label
[ __ ] it was really like out the pocket
from his video our people said that you
know what i'm saying it was on some real
[ __ ] [ __ ] it wasn't even like you know
it was supposed to be some label [ __ ]
but i guess that was taking too long
yeah busy's like
he's the best and you know what i like
about him is like you know you'll meet
somebody and you have an expectation of
who they are like a celebrity or someone
you look up to
and like you'll meet them and they
disappoint
nah he lives busy that is him
he's a
he is the same [ __ ] on the
internet in person like a [ __ ]
i like how he was just dedicated to
us at that time you know what i'm saying
i'm good
for me so he really like
he was herself though you feel me he was
[ __ ] with the business was that i was
saying was that something that like
y'all was like yo let's make an effort
to try to kind of
get uh someone from the south like a
legend just to expand the reach we have
because you guys got this side on lock
obviously what's gonna get who's gonna
try to get [ __ ] fredo bang on that
[ __ ] like we just wanted
somebody else out the reason you know
what i mean hit the marcus type [ __ ]
like yeah for sure that was the goal but
booster was definitely the one
yeah plus he gave you guys a great video
great he gave us a good ass verse too he
was popping it up today [ __ ] talking
about pvps and all that [ __ ] all right
we'll see
you guys
if you guys could pick uh like an og in
the game to do another collab album with
outside obviously you guys got one
together but who would you guys pick
any og anybody
somebody grew up listening to
a collabo
ice cube
cube would be crazy just like having
handled the production you ain't got a
rap i could do all that fun
do you see some of that og productions
and
yeah just like curate my [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying that's it what about you
bone
boom
i feel like that's extremely obtainable
at least one of the four members will do
an album listen yeah that was my
favorite favorite favorite group growing
up i feel like they still [ __ ] too
like boosie when you meet him
[Music]
yeah you could at least get busy boating
my booking agent no busy so yeah
something might go down oh wait you're
booking a age jamie adler yeah oh yeah
jamie knows yeah jamie's been working
with bone forever shout out to jamie by
the way
probably in australia right now
what's your like like
when you think of bone like what's your
favorite album from then
uh east 1999 that's the one yeah
yeah they came up they just came out
busting like don't change my i feel like
bone thugs and doggy style changed my
life bro because i got i got creeping on
a come up and doggy style was in the
same year when i was like five years old
my mom didn't know i had the tapes yeah
she see with me like i was like well i
was more than 94 so
like i was literally learning
like
when you got older yeah you had to go
back being gangster and [ __ ] so that
[ __ ] was so gangster to me like from
cleveland though
for sure nah that i think especially you
you got you got jamie adler in your he
make it happen yeah i love jake shout
out to jamie man you know what's crazy
is you know jamie now
you don't know
jamie the maniac i heard about jamie
though no jamie used to be a wild boy
a wild boy
but now he's like domesticated you know
what i'm saying silly
sure shout out to the homie jamie look
the album is out right now courtesy of
us
the
listen front to back crazy artwork is
crazy any more videos shot are you guys
uh done dropping videos not hell no no
like four or five more videos we got the
actual courtesy of a song video i think
that is negative yeah and then we're
about to shoot the one with kamiyah
that's gonna be crazy that's something
from that shoot going
after baby after party waiting we got
that one too there was something going
viral from that commander shoot what
happened no it's just going to go up
because you know just the theme of it is
going to be crazy it's a theme it's
going to be like us graduating and none
of us graduate no no
i got my me and kamaya got our ged and
i'm just thugging there's no ged nothing
but nobody walked the stage so this is
hard though like you know that's fire
that's super far i'm a tick-tock rolling
man
something going viral for something
there it is well i appreciate y'all
pulling up hey look we're gonna have a
freestyle too on the game so watch the
next video these guys doing what they do
best man it's the bullet head podcast
boom yes sir courtesy of us